sensor I would not wear sweatpants in  Prime no you would wear a um a bow tie  to the gym I would yes I I can't I I did  no I wouldn't count the gym as in public  I mean I'm saying you know right that's  one walking down the street I would not  but there was a period where the daily  wire was going to make a movie and I I  was told to beef up for this style I  remember when I said Body by lasagna I  wasn't capable  shoveling yeah yeah pasta pizza meat all  this stuff and I really did gain again  20 pounds and I cut my body fat in half  so it was actually muscle I never cut I  never actually cut yeah sure but I I no  you did it bro I totally I remember  first time in my life only time in my  life and I I did purchase a pair of  sweatpants for the occasion and a pair  of sneakers also yeah yeah and uh they  have not had much use since then did you  when you put them on did you scream  Adrian  I tried to break my nose a few times so  that it would look convincing